[MUSIC]
Okay, thanks everyone for
coming.
So it's my pleasure to introduce
Sebastian Ramacher from
the TU Graz in Austria.
Sebastian has been
working With Melissa and
I for both the last year on
a new signature algorithm.
He's on his way to CCS to
present the results next week so
he's gonna give us
the talk here today.
So welcome, Sebastian.
>> Thank you.
I'd like to thank Greg for
inviting me to stay here a few
days at Microsoft research.
So I'm going to talk
about signatures scheme
today which has been from
symmetric-key primitives.
This is besides Phyllis and
Greg also trying to work with
Stephen Godfritter
from Princeton.
Claudio from Aarhus University
in Denmark and Christian and
David from from the Austrian
Institute of Technology.
So maybe short overview
about Digital Signatures.
You would usually have a signer
with a public and private key
who can sign documents
using a the private key.
Then the verifier verifies
it using the public key and
checks if the signature
is valid.
It's used in many
products today from
certificate authorities
in TLS to
[INAUDIBLE] use cases
where a person can
identity itself or
in many applications.
But most of the RSA and
logarithm based signature
schemes become insecure in
a world where we consider.
This is due to
algorithm from 1994.
So new signature schemes have
been built based on our new
structures hardness
assumption from lattices,
from assumptions from
coding theory or
super singular and
other new assumptions.
There are also signature schemes
which are pulled from somatic
primitives, the most
prominent examples would
be swing switches and
hash based signature scheme.
Yeah, and so
we ask the question if there are
other alternative ways to build
a signature scheme also only
relying on symmetric primitives.
And we base our
signature scheme on two recent
progresses from recent years.
One is based on
recent work on symmetric-key
primitives that only require
very few multiplications, or
in our context, a few endgates.
And the other recent progress
we use here is,
Zero knowledge proofs for
general circuits that
have become practical.
And we build our signature
scheme on these two advances.
So we'll need one
third primitive,
which are called
signal protocols.
These are interactive protocols
where an approver wants to
convince verifier that
he knows something, and
they have these
three move formula.
First, approver commits to some
randomness then the verifier
sends a challenge
to the approver.
And based on the challenge,
approver sends some response,
and verifier can then verify
this statement by using
the response and the
recommitment to the randomness.
They are also known as
zero knowledge proofs and
can be very useful.
And they allow to build also
non interactive versions of
the serial knowledge pools,
a well known technique by
which is already very old.
On the one hand, this allows to
get a non interactive proof but
also allows to get a signature
scheme from any signal protocol.
In our case, we look at
a statement which is built from
a one-way function and
we have used a secret key and
input on one-way function and
the public key will contain the
image of the one-way function.
And then we use a SQL protocol
to prove knowledge of the input
on [INAUDIBLE] function and
use the future mu transform to
turn that into
a signature scheme.
So now let's look at an example
of such a sigma protocol.
So ZKBoo is a sigma protocol for
arithmetic circuits.
So any function you can
solely represent by
finite operations,
plus in the multiplication.
And it's based on a paradigm
bar which I had all which is
called MPC in the head where you
perform an MPC computation
on the approver side and
then you'll open some
of the computations.
And the basic idea
is the following.
You have some circuit, and
then you share this
circuit into three parts.
And, The idea here is that
if you have these three parts,
you can always reveal two of
them without revealing any
information on the secret input.
Then one commits to
the evaluation of this shared
circuit and can open two of the
evaluations to the verifier and
the verifier can then check the
consistency of the evaluation.
And here, every time we have to,
if there's a multiplication
in the circuit, we have to
take into account various
inputs from other branches.
So the efficiency of this
protocol heavily relies on
the number of multiplications
in the circuit.
So as a face contribution,
we've improved ZKBoo to
a variant that we call ZKB++.
And on one hand,
we have carefully identified
some values that we do not need
to be transmitted to obtain
the signal protocol and
also perform some optimizations
will require the random Oracle
model, which we'll have to use
anyway because we used a fusion
matrix form, and there we
have to use random oracles.
Then we've also removed many
checks that were in the original
protocol but which are rendered
obsolete by our optimizations.
So we can reduce the size
of the proofs by around
half the size but don't pay
any extra computational cost.
So I'm not going too much into
the details in what we did for
the optimizations, but some
were more easier observations.
Where we just defined
very carefully how we
performed the initial
secret sharing.
And use and appear and
cheat that we use any way,
where we have to
publish the seeds.
So we don't have to include
the inputs in the proofs and
can remove some parts of
the proofs, for example.
But then we also have some
optimizations where we require
the random Markov model.
And in particular, that we build
a signature scheme out of fit.
Whenever you perform this v to
mu transform, you have to hash
the commitments that were
sent in the first phase.
And so since, These
commitments that we hash here
also contain commitments already
that we view this
challenge that is computed.
It's a commitment to
a commitment and can remove some
of the commitments that we
would have to send otherwise.
Yeah, we do something similar to
the input, to the output shares,
to the input shares and
can remove something.
Can remove those shares because
we can recompute everything and
can then check the computation
was done correctly,
we are just one output share.
>> Now it sounds like you're
being computational costs
because you say-
>> Yeah, it sounds like that,
but on the other hand,
the original protocol had checks
after every multiplication that
the computation was correct.
But we use, again, here some
properties of the commitments
that they are binding.
So unless you've
computed that correctly.
So we remove all these checks
and use the binding of
the commitment to
check the computation,
and this saves a lot
of checks in between.
Then we also have another
optimization based on the random
marking model.
Where in the commitments
during the protocol if
you consider hash
based commitments,
you'd always add some
extra bits of randomness.
But since our first commitment
is the seat that we use for
the PHE, which is derived
randomly in the beginning,
we used the random oracle too.
So that we can reuse that
randomness in a commitment,
saving, again, some bits and
bytes that we don't have
to include in the proofs.
And then,
this is one of the major
optimizations that
saves a lot of data.
So when you verify the circuit,
you'll have to recompute
two of those branches and
we observe that you
can recompute one of
them simply with what
you have in the proof
that you need to
recompute anyway.
And, then again use binding of
the committment that you can
only recompute that correctly
if you see that the commitment
only verifies if the view
is computed correctly.
And so then we don't
need to start a view.
Okay, right.
So, I mentioned that we
build the signatures from
one way functions here.
So our first construction which
we called fish in the paper
which is now a picnic of S.
We used this circuit P++ and
an OEF is one is one of
the functions of the business
signatures scheme.
And here we use
the future mu transform.
And this gives us improved and
secure signature scheme in
the random oracle model.
But then if you consider
the future mutrants transform
signature scheme in random
oracle where the random
oracle is quantum accessible,
you'll have some problems.
The original, so the future mu
proofs requires rebinding and
it's not clear how to translate
that into the quorum setting.
There's some reason backed
by a rule which defines some
conditions where you
can transfer it.
But our construction doesn't
meet those conditions.
But fortunately there is
transform the codes and
transform which helps to
use similar technique to
get the signature scheme
out of sigma protocols.
And what this Unruh
transformation does it's
an extra random permutation and
you compute responses for
some of the possible
challenges and then you add,
apply the random permutation.
And produce the challenge
based on the output of
the permutation.
And then using this
transformation
we get signature
scheme which is,
uses again it can be prosperous
and one way function to
build provable secure
the signature stream in the QRM.
In the paper this was called
picnic which we now call picnic
UR for Unruh.
Right so, The Unruh
transformation incurs some
overhead since you'll have
to serialize more data including
some of the permutations
of the responses, so
it gets more expensive.
But we could get it down to
a factor of 1.6 compared to
the original future mu
transform signature scheme.
Right it's okay, this is output.
We need to select some
one way function which
works well with the set or
has a very small number
of multiplications.
So if you look at one of a
signature that is produced with
this technique you'll have
a factor that is influenced
by the number of multiplications
in the underlying ring or
underlying field size.
So you'll have some constant
c1 and c2 that, and c3,
that only, that depend on
the security level you want to
achieve which influenced by
the size of the committment,
size of the seat for the
pseudorandom number generator.
But then you have one factor
that is solely composed of
the multiplication
count of circuit.
So you're interested in
finding a circuit for
one way function with a very
small number of multiplications.
But also where it's not only a
small number of multiplication,
Where also the product
of the ring size and
the number of
multiplications is smaller.
All right, so we've looked
into some one-way functions
that one can build from block
ciphers and hash functions.
And so we've looked at AES,
SHA-2, SHA-3, and
all of them have a rather high
number of multiplications,
where you end up with rather
a product of the field size and
the number of multiplications
is over 4000 or
5000, or for
the hash functions, over 20000.
But there are some
new proposals for
lightweight primitives,
which all allow to
reduce this product.
And the best possible fit
in our case was LowMC,
which where we can get to in for
128 bit classical
security level, we can get
this product below 1000.
But this is very abstract, so
if you look at the final
signature size numbers,
you can see that if you
look at numbers for LowMC,
you look at signature sizes
which are around 100 kilobytes.
And for AES-based or something
like that, you look at 300
kilobytes, or for SHA, something
that is larger than 1 megabyte.
So let's take a short
look into LowMC.
So it's lightweight block
cipher design, which allows
to select the parameters based
on many different metrics.
So one can, Parametrize
in a way that you, for
example, minimize the number
of ANDs that have to be
computed per input bit.
Or also,
you can minimize the ANDdepth.
And so there are some example
of instances where each
of them minimizes one
of the three matrices.
For us here, since this
is in a binary circuit,
the number of ANDs is
the most important thing for
optimizing the signature sizes.
Also, one nice thing about LowMC
is that it can be parametrized
in a way that you can select
a very small data complexity,
which means that,
in our case, and
at first, we only see one
plaintext-ciphertext pair.
But this is a very unusual
setting for our block cipher.
But for LowMC, you'll have ways
to reduce the number of rounds
if you know that this smaller
data complexity is enough.
So we've looked into
different instances for
LowMC at 256 and 128-bit
classical security levels.
And you'll always get
pictures like that,
where if you increase
the number of ANDs and,
thus, increase the number
of the signature size,
you'll get a faster signing and
verification algorithms.
But pay that in
the signature size.
And if you try to reduce
the signature size and
reduce the number of ANDs, the
linear layer of LowMC becomes
very expensive and
the runtimes explode, but
you'll get smaller and
smaller signatures.
So we've selected instances and
some tradeoff between
a runtime and signature size.
So when we started to implement
the signature schemes,
we already got some
good runtime numbers
with around 30 milliseconds for
signing and verification
was a lot faster with
around 17 or 16 milliseconds.
But since then,
we were able to optimize these
algorithms a lot more, and
what we submitted now to the
NIST Post-Quantum Competition,
which is a lot faster signing
and verification times and
almost reduced it
by a half here.
All right, so
we've also compared it to
some other recent proposals,
in particular, to SPHINCS, which
is one of the other signature
schemes which only relies
on symmetric primitives.
And we've come closer to
their signing times, but
we can't beat their
verification.
They also achieved
smaller signatures, but
pay the price in this secret
key and public key things.
And then you can look
into signature schemes,
which are based on structured
hardness assumptions.
And there, the picture,
there's a lot,
you'll find signature
schemes which are good
at one of all the data points,
but not with all of them.
So you'll either have large
secret keys or public keys, but
smaller signatures, or larger
signatures but smaller keys.
But at least in those cases,
the runtime for
signing and
verifying is very good.
But for these latter schemes,
for example,
the signature generation
algorithms are very slow.
So at the first look,
our signature sizes look kind of
bad with around 129 kilobytes or
200 kilobytes for
the Unruh transform version.
But if you look at
the security level,
which in the NIST competition
is level one, which ask for
a 64-bit post-quantum signature
schemes, we can get that down to
around 30 kilobytes for the
Fiat-Shamir transform version or
52 kilobytes for
the Unruh transform version.
And also, the signing times
go down a lot to around 2
milliseconds, which isn't a lot.
Right, yeah, and
some of these improvements
were done by one our students,
Angela Promitzer,
who worked on improving LowMC
and the LowMC implementation.
And so I present to you
the LowMC encryption.
This looks like it's just very
less attractive, where you
start with you'll add an initial
round key to the plaintext,
and then you'll apply
the same round sometimes,
where you first apply
an Xbox layer, which doesn't
operate on the first state,
but just parts of it.
Then you'll add a linear layer,
where you multiply
the state with some matrix.
And then you add a round
constant and a round key.
Which is.
Yeah.
So in our case, the important
bits are the S-box.
It's the only place
where we have ends.
And the other important bits
are the linear layer which is
composed of the matrix
multiplication of the state
with the matrix and
where we compute the round key.
Which, so if you reduce
the number of S-boxes,
you'll increase the number of
rounds so you'll have more
matrix multiplications,
which then become expensive.
So, one of the problems that we
face in the signature scheme is
that the input, is that the
secret key is shared on every,
freshly shared on
every execution.
So you can't precompute
the round keys for example.
Which would be an obvious
optimization if you'd
use this as a proxy for you if
you recompute the round keys and
would get rid of one matrix
multiplication that you have
to do in every encryption.
But we can't do that here.
So, we are looking into some
optimization techniques
which we can perform without
involving the secret key.
So this is a typical run
of one of the LowMC runs.
You'll start with the s,
with the state,
and then apply the S-box
on some part of it.
Then you'll have
the multiplication with one of
the matrixes, and the round
constant, and the round key.
And so
what we're trying to do here is
this part of the state that
is not affected by the S-box.
So some of those,
some part of the round key and
some part of the constant only.
Affects this part which is
not affected by the S-box.
So we want to move everything
that doesn't touch the bits
interesting for the S-box
before we start all the rounds.
So, we move these
matrix multiplications
up as far as we can.
And then at some point we
have to split them in some
patent affects,
what we call nonlinear part.
Which is the part
affected by the S-box and
which only affects the linear
part which we can move up.
And so we repeat it until
all matrix operations that
only affect the linear part
at the beginning of the loop.
So we can remove the matrix
multiplication of the key
with the, with this, of the key
matrix with the secret key.
They're from and replace it
with one matrix multiplication
in the beginning with
some precomputed matrix.
And we only have to perform
one matrix multiplication in
the beginning using
the secret key and
kind of apply that to the state
directly before the first round.
So this is for the linear part,
and for the non-linear
part we can do something very
similar where we obtain for
each round similarly
looking matrix.
This matrix is a lot smaller
than the original matrices.
And we can combine all those
matrices into one larger one and
multi-perform this computation
also in the beginning.
And then split up the output of
that matrix multiplication into
the bits that affect each lever,
each round of the encryption.
So moving those matrices around
leads to quite a significant
performance increase
from around 30%.
Which.
So the blue bar, blue lines in
the original version without the
optimization and the green lines
then if you used the optimized
encryption algorithm.
And we can observe similar
figures on other platforms.
For example, this was, it has
the same performance gains on
our Right,
okay, so yeah.
Let me, yeah, let me end
with the conclusion here.
So it's, so with, I'm 100% it,
I said it could be plus,
plus which is an improved
zero knowledge proof for
[INAUDIBLE] circuits
which is half where
the proofs are only half
the size than said cable.
We were also able to
reduce the overhead from
the [INAUDIBLE] transform.
And presented two new signature
schemes in the Rhom and Kurhom.
Right, but the first part of
the optimization also has
of course other applications
anywhere you want to.
Have a, for example
a non-interactive zero knowledge
proof of some circuit
in a post setting.
Right, yeah, we've submitted
those two signature
schemes to the NIST Post Quantum
competition, but there's
also a lot of future work
that can be done in the area.
So the search for symmetric
primitives with a small
number of multiplications
is quite a new one.
So one might think there might
be another primitive other than
c with maybe even
less multiplications.
We also, one thing that would
lead directly to failed
optimizations, our sequences
queue would be more aggressive.
Parameter set based on some
analysis around the case where
you only see one or two plain
text, cipher text pairs.
Since if this case is
better understood, and
we could reduce the number of
rounds here that LowMC needs.
Then we'll get an automatically
faster signature scheme and
smaller signatures.
Right, and then one also topic
is of course some sectional
analysis of
the signature scheme.
Which is basically
one hand on LowMC and
if there are any
challenges which
would [INAUDIBLE] for example.
Right.
Yeah, thank you for attention
and have any questions?
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> [INAUDIBLE]
questions?
Okay, let's thank him again.
>> [APPLAUSE]